this video is made possible by the
free-to-play action game cross out check
out this game through the link in the
description below and you can start with
three extra weapons or a vehicle cabin
just for registering the Pacific Theater
of World War two was the largest
battlefield in world history tens of
thousands of square miles of ocean
punctuated by tiny islands and outposts
was bitterly contested for three and a
half years between the forces of the
United States and Japan Japan at the
time at one of the world's most powerful
navies and after dealing a devastating
blow to US forces of Pearl Harbor ins
attacking allied outposts all over the
Pacific they seemed invincible to stop
them the Navy calls on a mild-mannered
Texan who had led a bright but
unremarkable naval career for 35 years
his performance was nothing less than
spectacular within a matter of months he
had halted the Japanese advance and then
proceeded to force them back
across the Pacific to the doorstep of
their home islands resulting in their
surrender along the way Chester Nimitz
became one of the highest ranking
officers in US military history and one
of the most important commanders in the
history of the United States Navy this
is his story Chester W Nimitz was born
on February 24 1885 in the small Central
Texas town of Friedreich's Park his
father had died six months before he was
born in young Chester looked up to his
paternal grandfather Charles Henry
Nimitz colorful man who had immigrated
to the United States from Germany in the
1840s serving as a Texas Ranger a
captain in the Confederate Army and a
representative of the Texas state
legislature when he wasn't running the
hotel Nimitz in Fredericksburg Charles
had been a merchant sailor in Germany
and gave his grandson a lifelong
fascination with the sea however Chester
Nimitz didn't plan on a career in the
Navy he sought an appointment to West
Point in hopes of becoming an army
officer but there were no more open
slots from his congressional district
there was an appointment available to
the Naval Academy in Annapolis Maryland
however and
Nimitz was on his way he did well in
school graduating seventh in his class
in 1905 Nimitz became one of the first
generation of submarine officers but he
was also known for his engineering skill
he was assigned in 1912 to oversee the
building of diesel engines for the USS
more mere revolutionary oil tanker that
could refuel ships at sea instead of
them having to go into port
it was during this project that the ring
finger of his left hand was severed
after getting caught between turning
gears while conducting a demonstration
for visiting dignitaries the only thing
that saved the rest of his hand was his
Annapolis class ring getting caught in
the gear long enough for nimitz to pull
his hand out remarkably after being
treated at the hospital limits returns
to finish its demonstration Nimitz
continued in a successful if
unremarkable career trajectory over the
next two decades following the
conclusion of the first world war he
steadily gains promotions and more
important positions of responsibility
until he was promoted to Rear Admiral in
1938 and placed in charge of the Bureau
of navigation which despite its name was
largely responsible for personnel
decisions in this role he regularly
advised President Franklin Roosevelt on
senior command appointments and gained
the trust of the President as an officer
who told him what he needed to know
instead of what he thought he wanted to
hear
[Music]
on the 17th of December 1941 Admiral
Nimitz was called to the White House for
a meeting with Roosevelt
it had been 10 days since the Japanese
had attacked Pearl Harbor and pushed the
United States into World War two the
commander of the Pacific Fleet Admiral
husband Kimmel was being relieved it's
blamed in many quarters for how badly
unprepared the Navy was for the attack
although many historians today believe
Kimmel was made a scapegoat for failures
by more senior Navy personnel earlier
that year Roosevelt had offered commands
of the Pacific Fleet to Nimitz but
Nimitz turned it down not wanting to
leapfrog Admirals who were more senior
than he was but now the president wasn't
giving the choice Nimitz was promoted to
ranks to full four-star Admiral and
ordered to go to Hawaii immediately to
take command of the Pacific Fleet saw
what was left of it anyway the Pacific
Fleet had been decimated by the attack
the USS Arizona was sitting at the
bottom of the harbor tomb for more than
1,000 of her crew USS Oklahoma had
capsized USS Nevada had been
intentionally grounded by a captain to
prevent a sinking in all eight
battleships were either sunk or damaged
so badly that they were out of action
over 100 Army and Navy planes had been
destroyed on the grounds and over 2,400
men had been killed
Nimitz arrived in Pearl Harbor and
immediately took command of the
situation for 40 years the battleship
had dominated naval tactics but the
pacific fleet
didn't have any battleships what they
did have were aircraft carriers
fortunately for the u.s. the Pacific
fleets three aircraft carriers Lexington
Saratoga and enterprise were not in
Pearl Harbor on the day of the attack so
instead of supporting the battleships
Nimitz decided that the carriers were
now to form the centerpiece of the
Pacific Fleet an evolution in tactics
that changed naval warfare forever the
Japanese did not just attack Pearl
Harbor on December the 7th they also
attacked American bases and interests
all over the Pacific Nimitz's first job
was to prevent panic and calm everyone
down and this he was a master long known
as a mild-mannered officer he projected
an aura of serene calm around him at all
times never acting surprised or upset in
front of subordinates he needed that
calm now because things were going badly
the Japanese were victorious everywhere
they were
they had captured the British
strongholds of Singapore and Hong Kong
the Dutch East Indies and the American
outposts of Guam and Wake Island and
worst of all for the United States the
Japanese have forced the surrender of
the garrison of the Philippine Islands
the largest surrender of US forces in
history to make things even harder for
nimitz the president's and his War
Cabinet decided that the initial focus
should be on defeating Germany in Europe
so for the time being US forces in the
Pacific would get limited support from
the mainland nimitz would have to make
do with what he had and fight a
defensive war to give the united states
time to spin up war production and
speaking of war production just before
we get into the next half of the video i
do want to tell you about today's a
fantastic sponsor Crossout now you might
not be able to build a full-on aircraft
carrier and cross out but you can build
your own vehicle and pit it against
other people's constructed vehicles
cross out is a game that essentially
allows you to engineer something and
then go use it to destroy other people
some things it's fantastic now when you
think about that you might be thinking
is one of those games where you know you
get to choose the type of ammo and
that's about it but that's not the case
in cross out you get to build it from
the ground up you choose a main
structure and just build on up from
there stick on a rail gun
rocket booster some armor ends off you
go to fight easy if you build it well
you will dominate if you build it badly
you will get dominated that's how it
works
it's a super fast-paced game lots of
different game modes very easy to get
started and you've got pretty much
limitless freedom to create so join us
on the battlefield for free by the way
did I mention that the game is
completely free
and you can do it on PC Xbox one ps4
whatever you have just go through our
link below to get started you've got a
free starter set three extra weapons or
a vehicle cabin or as just a bonus for
registering and doing that is a great
way to support what we're doing here at
Baia graphics sponsors like cross out
really do you make this whole thing
possible so thanks to them for
sponsoring and let's get back to the
video
[Music]
his first move was largely symbolic
though very effective on April the 18th
1942 the aircraft carrier Hornet newly
transferred from the Atlantic secretly
sailed deep into enemy territory and
launched sixteen army b-25 bombers off
its flight deck the Bombers flew to the
Japanese home islands and bombed Tokyo
before continuing on to allied control
China the Doolittle Raid named after the
sorties commander colonel james
Doolittle did very little actual damage
but it provided a significant morale
boost to the American public and
panicked the Japanese High Command who
worried that their homeland was exposed
to danger by the American carriers the
Japanese made the next move launching a
seaborne invasion of the city of Port
Moresby the largest city in Papua New
Guinea and a key allied outpost in the
South Pacific
if the Japanese took it they would have
a base to launch air attacks on
Australia and New Zealand to stop the
invasion Nimitz sent a task force
centered around two of his carriers
Lexington and Yorktown to intercept them
the resulting Battle of the Coral Sea
was the first naval battle in history
that was fought entirely by aircraft the
two fleets never physically seeing each
other the Japanese were driven off from
Port Moresby but as heavy cost to the
American fleet Lexington was sunk and
Yorktown was damaged seemingly out of
action until she could be repaired at
Pearl Harbor for Japanese Admiral
Isoroku Yamamoto the Doolittle Raid and
the Battle of the Coral Sea demonstrated
that if Japan were to win the conflicts
with the Americans he needed to destroy
their carrier fleet once and for all he
set a trap for them his fleet would
attack and occupy the small yet
strategic American outpost on Midway at
all
west of Hawaii when the American fleet
sailed out to respond the Japanese would
destroy them what Yamamoto didn't know
was that American code breakers had
broken the Japanese radio codes and were
listening in on their messages they knew
in advance that the Japanese were going
to hit Midway and planned a trap of
their own the Americans sorted all three
available carriers from Pearl Harbor
Enterprise Hornet and Yorktown the
Yorktown had been repaired just enough
to get underway and participate in the
coming battle this was done at the
personal the hosts of Admiral
the commander of the task force was
admiral raymond spurns personally
appointed by nimitz after admiral
william bull Halsey ended up
hospitalized with severe shingles Nimitz
was risking everything in this battle if
he lost his carriers there would be no
serious naval opposition shielding
Hawaii or the American West Coast on the
4th of June 1942 the Japanese fleet with
four carriers launched their attack on
Midway the American carriers also
launched their planes against the
Japanese fleet which they had spotted
earlier that morning the cloud of
American planes found the Japanese
carriers catching them with planes on
their flight deck being rearmed and
refueled and dauntless dive bombers
promptly attacked and sank three of them
the Japanese counter attacked from their
last remaining carrier sinking the
Yorktown
but the Americans came back again and
sank the last Japanese carrier the scale
of the American victory at the Battle of
Midway defied belief four of the six
Japanese carriers that attacked Pearl
Harbor were now on the bottom of the
Pacific the victory did wonders for the
morale of the troops as well as the
American public who cheered their first
real victory after six months of bad
news the Japanese ability to attack
Hawaii again had been largely
neutralized by their defeat at Midway so
Nimitz decided to go on the offensive
after discovering that the Japanese were
constructing an airfield on the island
of Braddock canal in the Solomon Islands
it was decided that the island needed to
be taken to prevent the Japanese from
possessing a base to threaten the Allied
offensive in New Guinea the 1st Marine
Division supported by army troops landed
on Guadalcanal on August the 7th 1942
initially taken by surprise the Japanese
pulled back and the Americans captured
the airfield naming it Henderson Field
after a pilots that had been killed a
Midway the Japanese poured all available
manpower into attempting to retake
Henderson Field and pushing the
Americans off Guadalcanal and for the
next six months both sides fought a
bloody battle of attrition on land at
sea and in the air by the time the
Japanese finally evacuated the islands
in February 1943 almost 30,000 were dead
on both sides but the Americans were now
on the offensive in the pacific and
Nimitz and the Joint Chiefs of Staff
meant to keep up the momentum
Nimitz helped devise an island hopping
strategy
to defeat Japan the Allies would capture
strategic Islands held by the Japanese
to advance on the Japanese home islands
but not every island fortified positions
would be bypassed and isolated their
supply routes cut off but they wouldn't
be invaded in order to save lives and
resources this clashed with the ideas of
his army counterparts and General
Douglas MacArthur who favored a direct
approach from Australia to Japan via New
Guinea as well as the Philippines
President Roosevelt compromised
splitting the Pacific into two major
theaters of war the southwest Pacific
commanded by MacArthur and the Pacific
Ocean area commanded by Nimitz this
prevented a power struggle between the
Army and the Navy and kept both the
bombastic MacArthur and more reserved
Nimitz happy Nimitz's area of
responsibility was largely quiet for
most of 1943 as he built up the
resources to wage offensive war and
while MacArthur slugged it out with the
Japanese on the Solomon Islands and on
New Guinea however Nimitz
was able to strike a strategic blow
against Japan in 1943 when his code
breakers discovered the travel itinerary
of Admiral Isoroku Yamamoto commander of
the Japanese combined fleet and the
masterminds behind Pearl Harbor and the
Battle of Midway Army planes were able
to intercept and shoot down the plane
carrying Yamamoto killing him and
dealing a huge morale blow to the
Japanese public
[Music]
by November 1943 Nimitz was ready he
began his campaign in the Gilbert
Islands invading these strategic islands
of Tarawa and smackin taking both after
four days of battle and 7,000 dead on
both sides they used these occupations
as a forward staging area against the
Marshall Islands which were taken in
1944 next was the Marianas and Palau
Islands these were important to the
campaign because if they could be taken
they would be able to reach the Japanese
home islands with land-based bombers the
Marianas campaign kicked off with the
invasion of Saipan in June 1944 in
response the Japanese Navy sorted all
available carrier forces to stop them
and engage the Pacific Fleet in a
decisive battle the resulting Battle of
the Philippine Sea was a disaster for
the Japanese the Americans sank three
Japanese carriers and destroyed over 550
aircraft crippling Japanese air power
for the rest of the war due to the ease
of which they shot down Japanese planes
this battle became known to the
Americans as the great Marianas turkey
shoot next to fall were the islands of
Guam and Tinian and then The Plough
Islands meanwhile MacArthur was ready to
invade the Philippines invading the
islands of later in October 1944 Nimitz
in his role as commander of the Pacific
Fleet was responsible for ensuring the
safety of the landing force from attacks
by the Japanese Navy the Japanese only
had a few carriers left so when they
steamed south from Japan with the
mission of bombarding the troops on
Later they relied on their battleships
including the Yamamoto and the Musashi
the largest battleships ever built the
Battle of Leyte Gulf was a violent
affair with 15,000 casualties it was
another disaster for the Japanese who
suffered the loss of 26 ships
this included the battleship Musashi as
well as the last of the carriers who had
attacked Pearl Harbor in 1941 this
battle was the first time the Japanese
sent out organized camicazi attacks a
plane deliberately crashing into the
American carrier sand low resulting in a
sinking but as for the Japanese Navy it
was finished they never sailed forth in
any strength again now limits could
return his attention to his own campaign
but not before receiving a singular
honor in December of 1944 Congress
created the Navy rank of Fleet Admiral
five-star Admiral
for the first time in history Chester
Nimitz was one of four Admirals to be
promoted to Fleet Admiral thus making
him one of the highest-ranking officers
in not only the history of the Navy but
in US military history in February 1945
the marines invaded the volcanic island
of iwo jima one of the last stepping
stones to Japan in the five weeks it
took to secure the islands the Americans
suffered 26,000 casualties the Japanese
18,000 the closer the Allies got to the
Japanese home islands the fiercer the
Japanese fought they were fanatical in
their devotion to duty preferring to die
than be taken prisoner fighting to the
death and taking many American lives in
the process no other battle in the
Pacific War demonstrated this fanaticism
better than the Battle of Okinawa
Okinawa was the plan's major staging
area for the invasion of the Japanese
home islands unlike most of the islands
contested so far Okinawa had a large
civilian population and one of the
largest Japanese Garrison's anywhere
outside of the home islands Nimitz was
worried about heavy casualties but
nobody predicted the vast scale of the
destruction it took ten weeks from April
to June of 1945 for the Allies to take
Okinawa but at a fearful cost 160,000
casualties 75,000 of them American it's
also estimated that a further 150,000
civilians were either killed or
committed suicide convinced by
government propaganda that the Americans
were monsters who would eat their
children Nimitz and other Allied
planners were faced with the grim
reality that this was only a taste of
what they could expect when they
launched operation downfall the planned
invasion of Japan itself
they knew that despite being bombed
regularly by the new b-29 heavy bomber
destroying Japanese infrastructure and
war materiel Japan had no intention of
giving up they were training a civilian
militia that was 28 million strong in
some cases armed only with Spears with
the intention of having every last man
woman and child in Japan fight to the
death to resist the invaders the price
that America would have to pay to occupy
Japan scared Nimitz and every other
American commander it also scared new
President Harry Truman who assumed
office after President Roosevelt died in
April Truman authorized the use of two
atomic bombs on Japan
in an attempt to force their government
to surrender first at Hiroshima on
August the 6th then at Nagasaki on
August the 9th the devastating new
weapons killed a quarter-million people
with thousands more dying in the
subsequent years from the effects of
radiation poisoning burns injuries or
cancers Japan finally agreed to
surrender on August the 15th spurred on
by both the atomic bombs and the entry
of the Soviet Union into the war against
Japan on September the 2nd the Japanese
formally surrendered to the Allies
aboard the battleship Missouri in Tokyo
Bay Admiral Nimitz was in attendance
accepting the surrender on behalf of the
United States world war ii the largest
most destructive and deadliest conflicts
in the history of mankind
was over Admiral Nimitz was fated by the
American public after the war receiving
tributes and awards across the country
as well as significant military honors
from other countries including the order
of Bath from Great Britain and the
Legion of Honor from France he succeeded
his wartime boss Fleet Admiral Ernest
King as the Chief of Naval Operations
the highest-ranking officer post in the
Navy in December of 1945 his primary job
as CNO was to oversee the drawdown of
the Navy's forces from the massive war
buildup had experienced and which could
no longer sustain in the national budget
however he left one more significant
legacy on the Navy when he supported
Hyman rickover plan to build the USS
Nautilus the world's first
nuclear-powered submarine helping usher
in the age of the nuclear propulsion
system Nimitz retired from his post to
CNO in 1947 but wasn't officially
retired from the Navy as a fire
Starfleet Admiral he was considered to
be on active duty for the rest of his
life continuing to draw full pay and
benefits as a reward for exceptional
service Nimitz's post retirement life
was largely quiet except for a four-year
stint serving as a diplomatic
administrator for the United Nations in
the disputed region of Kashmir from 1949
to 1953 Nimitz died at his home in San
Francisco On February the 20th 1966 at
the age of 18 he was buried at Golden
Gate National Cemetery in California
alongside one of his closest friends and
comrades from the war Admiral Richard
Turner he would later be joined by two
more friends
Admiral Charles Lockwood's in 1967 and
Admiral Raymond's piron's in 1969 as
well as his wife Catherine in 1979
perhaps the most fitting tribute to this
great military leader occurred in 1975
when a new aircraft carrier was launched
the leadership of a class of 10 aircraft
carriers that still serve as the
backbone of the modern United States
Navy this ship was named USS nimitz the
only one of ten that wasn't named for a
president or politician it seems only
right to sow honor a man who oversaw the
transformation of the aircraft carrier
from support ship to fleet centerpiece
and in so doing became the Admiral that
defeated Japan and conquered the Pacific
so I really hope you found that video
interesting if you did smash that like
button below and don't forget to
subscribe also please do support our
fantastic sponsor cross out that's free
by the way link to below
and thank you for watching
[Music]